Now we just finished talking about drug therapy as a biological treatment. So
let's move on to the second major area of biological treatment and that is
psychosurgery. Psychosurgeries involve medical procedures on the brain in an
attempt to alleviate the symptoms of psychological disorders. Now the first
psycho-surgery going to discuss was actually widely over-used, and had tragic
consequences including sometimes death. This is the pre-frontal lobotomy. The
lobotomy involved cutting the connection between the pre-frontal cortex and the
lower area of the brain. Now this technique is no longer used today. But if you
think back to the material on lesson three in the brain and behavior, you'll
see why this procedure dramatically changed the individual. We know that the
prefrontal cortex is important in thinking, and it's imperative for working
memory and planned action, and the lower area of the brain is more concerned
with emotion. Therefore, some believe the surgery will have the affect of
modifying behavior and perhaps disengaging the disruptive thought patterns
associated with hallucinations and confused thinking. In reality the procedure
produced profound personality changes, often leaving the person listless or
appearing absent. In addition there was a likelihood of experiencing seizures.
In many cases, people were left in a vegetative state. Now the lobotomy was
performed by taking a sharp instrument and placing it near the corner the eye,
hammering that in, and then moving the instrument back and forth, thereby,
modifying or destroying parts of the brain.